hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by Danny Brown you can
catch him on a festival stage near you
this summer and you can pick up his
album atrocity exhibition available now
Danny welcome to the show how are you
with hot food Oh terrible smelling noise
we're starting to get to Megan coming
through the jars
look I got a technique on my chicken
wing cons it - so you're not going to
side
you spin it I want to start by talking
about Tony Yayo because he's kind of a
mythical figure on the history of our
show when we first started it we called
up Tony and Tony actually helped us
workshop the show and if I have your
origin story right isn't he the one that
you kind of credit with helping get your
career on the ground yeah
yo-yo is in Detroit shoot in Swat - and
you need just hit me up the day you know
I came round and Chelios amusingly with
me today yeah and I just I know a little
more 2804 like a summer and it's kind of
an interesting origin story because Tony
Yayo took you under his wing
but then 50 cent really liked your music
but what it was some white jeans as the
wing jeans
yeah what tell white jeans to it but
that was way like a fan effect he taught
me to start wearing skinny jeans and he
gave me like these weird like James with
like bedazzles and stuff floating like
hundred dollar bills falling off the
pocket but I warned for a minute but you
know girls I admit I used to go a little
extreme in those days you do more stuff
than now I doubted back a little bit
yeah you know I wear a longer shirt now
but did I let you see the boat it's my
home you you love Tabasco I mean I can
eat it with some like some gizzards you
know stance move some deep fried liver
he knows that I am real boy Grinch like
what's next in the connections to hot
ones they don't stop with Tony Yayo
you're big Joey Coco Dee's van
I love Coco in a church what's happening
now man you love Joe in Burma yeah you
did the theme song for Eddy long and if
I have the math right TJ Miller that's
your guy right my best friend's right
there would you describe your
relationship I really enjoy because he
makes me he'd make me laugh you just
have so much fun like always think like
I'm like the wild crazy guy I'm just
gonna have fun and stuff I get around
here
it is like I got it taken take a back
seat do his thing
do you remember how you guys met oh we
met at Bonnaroo that's a plan Hannibal
actually was a cool thing at Bonnaroo
because the security came to me and it
was like yo you want some of this no
Mike what are you talking about and I'm
looking back and he just had a bag full
of drug that they took from all the
people that was coming into the festival
you know those like oh that's so cool so
I just you know a little trick or treat
so they all knew everybody knew I had to
trick-or-treat so it was like come party
come party
do you know found a few friends that
like the party to say god damn it's hot
though for you Danny I'm a little
nervous you might be 35 years old and I
don't want you to take this are you 35
sometime I forget oh yeah right
you think anyone a March March 81 so
you're gonna turn 36 and March oh yeah
type but you have the sensibilities of a
sixth grader I've I've heard you talk
about your ideal day and you said
playing video games smoking blunts
watching cartoons ordering a pizza go
into bed so what I've done is I've
pulled some Adult Swim mainstays and I
just want to get your reaction to the
movie think I'll just hit you with them
and you just tell me the first thing
that comes to your mind okay
are you an Aqua Teen Hunger Force at my
school my school look Oh trip I bring it
to you the theme song like good morrow
swim is amazing man I put a hooker first
man I mean my old girlfriend we actually
had a great connection but that we're
first date we watched my first season
Aqua teens you binge watch a TV show
we've been together ever since what
about regular show regular sewers like
my friends I kind of feel like I really
know those guys even though it's like I
was grilling a bird but if they was like
real
they've got my [ __ ] what about Rick
and Morty lots of rappers like Rick and
Morty here Ricky Maria's real deep
I think is deeply what people think they
just look at [ __ ] Oh surface-level and
me always got to get extra in Toledo so
wicked Morty I would say I mean I could
go a little longer but they already
topic but I would say it's a little
creepy
looks a little creepier than what you
think you go to see and then this isn't
a cartoon but I have to ask you about it
because you did the Eric Andre show and
you did a bit called rapper ninjas or
your ninja yeah and I asked Eric about
it and that bit specifically he said
that you took some convincing on that
one oh yeah I was being a dick about it
but hey what's that same [ __ ] night
relevant for the American Gladiators
when I was ready for the fade I'm like I
don't know what are you about to do to
me you can have people put hands on me i
watch this show all the time here I
notice a but [ __ ] - your hand will be
pulling so I'm just making sure that we
steel friends you know after you pull
some [ __ ] on me I'm a postman [ __ ] - so
but end up turning out good I just [ __ ]
on yourself instantly copy that don't
work I want to talk to you about being a
homebody for a second because you and me
are same wavelength on that one I don't
really want to go out I want to spend
every night inside and there are a lot
of amateurs out there who think it's
just about Netflix and chill it but it's
not the professionals like you and me we
know that there's a lot more involved in
that do people come they like to have
friends around it or is it just you and
the cats communicate for the most part
but I do like a view of sea fights or
some come over I have water homies I do
stuff like that
I like fight nights favorite fighters my
favorite fighters of course I love the
women you know Holly Holm is one of my
favorite and your line is your chick is
Johanna Carter would call her what she's
a fighter she's she's just so pretty
time you see the Sun like I want to just
like stroke her hair till it be okay to
[ __ ] out you gotta love this so sexy
alright so the next part of the show is
a recurring segment called explain that
Graham and you know this show it's where
we bring out the laptop we've done a
deep dive on your Instagram
interesting pictures that we think need
more context and shockingly surprisingly
we've never done in all food addition
I've explained that Graham today we are
a little thing called what the hell is
Danny Brown eating pulled that is a rad
new foot dumb food about the grip all
right so this first one is interesting
you have the oh yeah those are my
macaroons I love those shuts up the home
utopia firms send me some macaroons for
that new cameras give me the macaroons a
lot of times you know you brown you some
it's like ass right we you know but this
really tastes good like it's really good
macaroon hain't start eating Becca rolls
into I had some wheat in it what the
hell is going on here we have a hot dog
tag we have slavery and they have this
hot dog spot now that hot dog there I
did not eat
you never so don't think I'm a savage
like this where I eat things like this
the hot dog there I did eat we had it we
had we had a bet with all the homies no
the homies was like okay I order a hot
dog and you gotta eat it you know I'm
saying my home the hot dog that I had to
eat my homey order peanut butter and
jelly on it it wasn't even that bad yes
the craziest Bloody Mary right nobody
know you're just waking on the game you
just run it for the gram hun it out it's
about it demands Bloody Mary for y'all
to say dumb [ __ ] in the comment
what's special mm-hmm did you like it no
we've talked to a lot of fevers and got
their start either in the drive-through
or maybe they got their start as waiters
but your culinary experience is pretty
unique
can you talk to me about being the guy
in jail who handed out sandwiches oh not
a job that you had in jail you that was
Woody's gonna talk to me about the
challenges of that yeah cuz the
niccola's Blake let me get an extra
mustard and Foley's bright only given on
[ __ ] no extra mustard
you know the saying you ain't gonna be
down here normal behavior steal
cigarettes back ain't giving out no
mustard and he could be like well you
ain't giving you a musty old wannabe
police ask [ __ ] give me the extra
mustard ain't [ __ ] so you damn rate
about to fight every day over packs of
mustard and giving me the sandwiches and
[ __ ] so it took some thick skin again
you cut the wire cuz you know you in
jail with them you write all here
together but they look at you like you
some type of snitch or something yeah
don't even understand like why is Danny
not giving me much what's in it for a
really [ __ ] with you for having it cuz
it's a good job to have it weren't you
working also at a buffet cookie buffet
you weren't at an old country but wholly
fine I worked at the sweet house to
order stuff they make any touchin lady
friends don't appear to put out there
that's fine
that's cool but she they gotta get his
coat no don't do it
[Music]
another feeling this one gonna be house
[ __ ] one of my favorite things about
Danny Brown the artist is the lyrics
everybody put out an album I'm on genius
I'm looking through and as I'm listening
to the album I'm reading what you write
so what I've done is I've pulled some of
my favorite Danny Brown food references
and I for you just annotate them genius
style okay tell me what it means okay
tell me where you were in your life when
you wrote it all mean what inspired you
you know what I mean
okay first one is on my favorite call
tell me what I don't know jump and don't
finish that's Owen that's what credit
take it turns can you see how things
copacetic
it's like [ __ ] tomato with you always
butter lettuce Oh slice of tomato I
guess I really wanted to be like Adam's
apple but you couldn't say I don't have
them so that salad all right this next
one's I'm monopoly really like cool read
through those Statham [ __ ] like people
pick out but I like Cool Ranch Doritos
but I guess these people always just a
scooby-doo don't smell bad that's what
it was this next one's from downward
spiral
but I eat these [ __ ] wrappers my
[ __ ] last steak if that's like a
views on death row and you wanted your
own glass me like a so since I might
tell you but I want to state you know
and I'm saying I you know I could I'll
rap other rappers the same way I'll
enjoy a tasty steak on death row but I
think the whole comparing and eating
rappers they get starting to get a
little weird
oh I don't want to say that all right so
this one is the de Brahm beyond insanity
hot so I just write and crisscross
mm-hmm
Sam Bishop the bomb the same way there's
no looking back there are no more
free-throws Danny Brown there are no
more fries I always live vicariously
through people who've attended the
gathering of the Juggalos because on one
hand it seems like such a mecca for all
who go there but not on the other hand
the campgrounds seem like such a
minefield and I'm sure that the Porta
Potty situation is a nightmare
can you give me the Danny Brown guide to
surviving gathering of the Juggalos me
personally I like cousin Tom freaking it
was some freaky [ __ ] going on you know
how to get dark you go back in it get it
get nasty you know so I'm like a boy
yard I like to watch it [ __ ] you know
what I'm saying so I was going over
there and they might be in creepy yeah
that's what it'll be like that maybe a
little too PC like but jugglers you can
be yourself what sorts of things did you
see I saw a [ __ ] contest you did a
contest they are working that's a
question I want to get in it oh come on
ma'am next foot it's like I got a chill
man and they do it for the family just
like but then I was like I don't know
how long get my dick suck my crown they
got some hot juggler [ __ ] though a
lot of people don't know and you think I
just thought that weird like me with
Lucy's are eating [ __ ] with that [ __ ]
no they cuss some bad [ __ ] with some
crown paint on your face really yeah you
wouldn't it what is the male to female
ratio because I feel like it's got to be
stacked male it's got to be three times
as many guys for everything it's not
available pretty split there's a lot of
people come in as couples you know
jugglers ain't single are you ready to
move on
goddamn
and so this next one is mad dog 357
Danny how you feeling all right we're
gonna do this I respect it I love it
Danny huh sigh control damn made it last
was the bombing [ __ ] I mean it is bunny
congratulations on getting your driver's
license we got drink milk how do you
like new we got whole milk just for you
Danny
god damn congratulations on getting your
driver's license you got that pretty
recently right yeah yeah that's crazy
because you grew up in Detroit
I cannot imagine growing up in Detroit
not having a driver's license why did it
take so long Danny Brown cuz I got hit
by a car I was just scared of cars and
[ __ ] and then and you trade two cars are
so easy to come by a lot of people had
cars so by Tommy's house me like get my
life is in drive a car yeah I wanted to
do that you're not tempted
well I'm afraid that cars so just made
me more of these are about doing it and
for them I like 25 like [ __ ] I'm gonna
try getting the car to them guy hey what
the [ __ ] are you doing it right you know
what
then I wanted of course you can't get a
Porsche got a driver's license
so this one has Blair's Megadeath sauce
with liquid rage it is the hottest hot
sauce that we have on the board and is
very hot it's tradition around here to
dab the last wing with a little bit
extra you don't have to if you don't
want to Danny Brown but I just put a
little drop just for the people out
there I mean yeah I'm not gonna go I'm
not don't want to go against tradition
okay changes all right so this one's
Blair's Megadeath sauce with liquid rage
oh my shake the last question is this
you know Time Warner you are that would
be a first I think with us alright
alright so there are a lot of reasons to
like Danny Brown and we've covered many
of them today but what I think is the
most lovable thing about Danny Brown is
the affection that you have for your
cat's I love my business siren and Chia
so while we take this last bite and
we're dying on the hot wing I want you
in as much detail as possible to
describe your love for your cats okay oh
okay okay
I'm okay but yeah I think the one reason
I love my cats the most the most animals
you love you anyway cuz you feed them
like what kids don't give a [ __ ] about
your life with me you know you gotta
earn that affection you know siren is
more like a diva she just changed [ __ ] I
just wanna lay around she he's a savage
like me like a cat but I keep like a dog
you know I just say I don't like dogs
and [ __ ] all goes like a bug flew in a
house like I don't know those bug they
make weird noises don't like buzzing
how loud was that bug noise in his head
like cuz it was what you don't go [ __ ]
about a dog you had everyone forget
sitting on the back porch
oh when alone I would you a cat fight
waiting on drunk one like so I'm
thinking of weed like with like kindred
souls mm-hmm Danny you made it and it
cleared the wings it was amazing it was
incredible orgasm let the people know
what you have going on in your life Oh
teni brow I got can't set the house and
I like to play video games and have
album track the exhibition go buy that
[ __ ] because I might not be here show me
some love
while my shakin
[Music]
stank [ __ ] smelling stank [ __ ]
smelling smelling like Cool Ranch
Doritos hey what's going on hot ones
fans if you like the video maybe meet us
halfway throw us a subscribe if you
didn't like the video don't subscribe I
don't want you I don't want you in the
tent but if you like the video subscribe
thank you very much I appreciate you I
love you more than a friend